yeah hello and welcome to this video ffv
are my mooch is my opponent what is 0-2
I think what can I do let's see a
Queen's Indian don't quite remember
where I've played them twice before but
I don't remember anything to get her
very quick win against and only recently
i'm not mistaken
and usually black play some place the
move on a six in such a situation i
wonder if that is really if not get five
is doing anything serious him does it
look like it we need to is looking at
the a6 pawn make it more difficult for
him to move the focus on the other hand
there's a slightly to plan that now does
not work anymore so maybe a shrimp it
could see turn I don't have huge
experience with this position tired but
I play it once in a while in the grip
scales it's a bit difficult I think to
to to a cell this on c5 swords in the
air I think we need to was probably not
a good idea look at it now it looks
pretty strange
you my ideas 95 as his headless
unprotected this move would be
technically possible he cannot take
twice up here let me play 95 yes he's
having a saying he cannot take a couple
of times there and now I'm threatening
at three end of three possibly at for
some time with him the stent work okay
97 I cannot play it's a queen each phone
okay let's just let's just make sure I
keep this piece queen h4h three might be
dangerous make dangerous wow just twin
Knight to f6 yeah how do I get something
going here not easy
try to reroute this jeff three it really
doesn't do anything on youtube so what's
going on here Queen g7 hey it looks
extremely dangerous let's clear it's got
lots of pieces has my position i'm
thinking maybe not g5 is possible here i
have to do something like that i don't
think a passive defense would work
going on here night reform what's the
deal 94th threatens on h2 and 93 check
wow that looks like difficult to answer
move ok here is called a million
discoveries ok let's get out of that I
am if I take here at night age three
chicken aid and here you threaten screen
is three I guess who g3 is not quite
working
a queen III is winning is winning Queen
f2 loop g3 is checkmate queeny's reroute
f2 group g3 King f1 maybe continues but
he can take with the Queen 1g3 as well
so Queen III is an easy win now I just
wonder what what tougher you'll fail is
to find Queen f2 is probably best I mean
it loses and everything losers but check
and it was a really bad game yeah gently
I was a terrible game and gas starting
with the bed opening set up somehow I
think I mean this is of course normal
but this is maybe already kind of wrong
Queen Sita was probably a better choice
I have lost some moves down and while he
went for this is a very straightforward
attack which yeah I know it shouldn't be
all that dangerous but it's become very
can become very dangerous yeah he should
be 594 was already winning yeah this
idea was winning the whole time probably
yeah it was just not a good position
he's got all the attacking pieces most
multiple ways to win again this is the
maiden
remember that absolutely absolutely wow
what did i do here I mean still okay
Queenie to see to what was rubbish okay
but I should not get just get checkmated
here at that that's just not going to
that's just not the best I mean I should
still have some kind of position here
engine gives Knight c3 I know it was
kind of an off game I never really I've
never really understood what was going
on kind of a kind of a long game thanks
for watching